[Music]
[Music] he
said
I don't have
[Music]
and
i
[Music]
télam
also had an automatic machine for
tubutama
this machine in both issues
taking
the warning fan
as with inside a backpack
we here almost without agreement toilet
[Music]
data  like a canteen to the mister
here it exists because of the protections bathing
like emily for the conditional command
and that we are at peace almost schukin to
cook in support a progress that is not
without angaité park to garamba we go to the
leg
[Music]
the  land like cannes and manga in the
cob and mal
[Music]
limestone
canessa who dances and
ramón and much
a vein that is worth my saint
and I here for many years
and here
suzuki
[Music]
derived from  the television
and by the way
to the doctor
granier this pattern
fails me with mango ming and healthy
I have a psychiatrist
[Music]
this week obama
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
manzana
both have each other  the indices with
water
no narrowness and mined great
Christian that does not fall to dwellers
[Music]
no